welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact one summer day in 2014
booboo a cat went missing from her home
in Watsonville California three years
later the brown tabby reappeared in
southeastern Canada so how did this cat
end up more than two thousand miles away
from home when booboo arrived at the
Ontario Humane Society is astray she
hardly looked like a scruffy tired
traveller the cat was slightly fat and
her striped fur was soft and groomed
Adrianne McBride the executive director
of the animal shelter said she is in
fantastic shape
she's so well fed she might need to go
on a diet when she gets home the cats
Watsonville owners were shocked and
happy to get a phone call from Canada
just how the missing cat got there
remains a mystery well at least until
cats can talk but Ashley almond her 21
year old owner has a hunch the cat went
hitchhiking almond says that booboo was
an outdoor cat that had a curious habit
of hopping in strangers cars booboo may
have hitchhiked her way across the
border with one or multiple drivers
lucky for this traveling feline she was
microchipped when the cat arrived at the
Humane Society the chip revealed her
surprisingly far off home address
almond flew to Canada to reunite with
and recover her wandering cat the truth
about Boo Boo's 3-year adventure may
never be known but did you know the
Bible says that people can also have a
tendency to wander stay tuned friend
we're going to learn more in this
edition of Bible answers live
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at
1-800-805-3030
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you're tuning in for
the first time you can probably tell
from the title this is a live
international interactive Bible study
we've been doing this for about 20 years
now on hundreds of stations across North
America and of course everybody is
around the world via the internet but if
you'd like to call in with your Bible
question lines are wide open right now
and here's the number it is of course a
free phone call in North America 800 God
says that's eight hundred four six three
seven two ninety seven you probably have
a Bible question you're looking for a
pencil so I'll say that again eight
hundred four six three seven two ninety
seven I sometimes say the number
multiple times because we've got people
listening by satellite driving across
the country and maybe they've got to
memorize it or find something to write
with
800 calling your Bible question for 63
72 97 my name is Doug Batchelor pastor
John Ross is off for the night but we're
going to start this program with a word
of Prayer loving Lord we just thank you
again for the opportunity and even the
technology to be able to talk to so many
friends in so many places about the most
important thing your word and your truth
be with us Lord bless this program for
your glory sake and for the salvation of
others in Jesus name we pray amen well
you may have guests friends when I
talked about the story of boo-boo
the wandering cat and I said sometimes
we can have the capacity to wander I was
thinking of that verse and Isaiah 53
where there the Prophet says all we like
sheep have gone astray we've turned
everyone to his own way and the Lord
laid upon him
Jesus the iniquity of us all our
wandering has been very costly for the
Lord
you know Jesus told a parable in Matthew
18 he said what do you think if a man
had a hundred sheep and one of them had
gone astray does he not leave the
ninety-nine on the mountains safe in the
fold in other words and go search for
that one that went astray and if he
finds it truly I say to you he rejoices
over it more than over the 99 that never
went astray so it is the will of not the
will of my father in heaven that one of
these little ones should perish the Lord
is willing to make a long trip from
heaven to earth to reach his lost sheep
and that's why Jesus came into this
world and you think about that girl
Ashley who flew from California to
Canada to pick up her wandering cat now
I sat on an airplane last week with a
young lady that had a cat in her lap
next her and even though the cat cage
made her a little uncomfortable and kind
of cramped her in her seat she just
spent the entire four-hour flight trying
to calm and nurture and and soothe her
cat during the stress of a flight a
people really loved their pets and if
people can love their animals how much
more does God love his children that he
even gave his son that they might be
redeemed and maybe you're one of those
wandering sheep friends maybe you're
somebody who knew the Lord and you've
drifted you'd like know how to come home
or how to get a new beginning with God
we have a free book for you it's called
12 steps to revival 12 steps to revival
written by yours truly and I think
you'll enjoy this and it's kind of the
keys to a personal new beginning and if
you call the number we'll send you one
here's the resource number it's a little
different 808 3 five six seven four
seven eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven for the book twelve
steps to revival just tell them you're
listening to Bible answers live and
they'll share that with you you can even
download it for free right now at the
amazing facts website that's easy to
find it's amazing facts got no RG and
you type in amazing facts calm you'll
still end up at the amazing facts
website go to the free book library and
you'll see 12 steps to revival alright
friends with that lengthy introduction
we're going to go to the phones want to
just tell you for we do once more we do
have other lines open now is a good time
to call if your phone rings for a minute
that's a good sign that means that
you're going to be in line and someone
will pick up and I just jot down your
information all right we're going to
talk to Julie he's calling from Upland
California Julie you're on the air with
Bible answers live I pastor Doug good
evening um my question is trying to
understand righteousness by faith and
how does God imputes that to us and one
does he do that and do we know when he
does ad well what is righteousness by
faith first let me explain this now I
think you may know something about it
Julie but a lot of our listeners might
be wondering we're in a lost condition
when we sin we do wrong it's the
opposite of righteousness it's wrong
justice of course there's no such a word
but it's doing bad it means you're in a
lost unjustified condition if we want to
be forgiven and declared righteous
something has to happen Christ says look
I will die in your place for your sins
penalty for sin is death I take your
sins if you accept by faith my
righteousness because I've never sinned
I will trade places with you I will take
your badness
I give you my goodness like the thief
who was on the cross next to Jesus when
Christ said you know I'm forgiving you
you will be with me in paradise
immediately when he accepted that by
faith he was made righteous he was
declared to be righteous and that's what
you call justification he accepted Jesus
righteousness by faith that's the good
news
and he was justified just as he was now
if he had come down from the cross he
would have had time to experience
sanctification that's where you learn to
kind of live a new kind of holy life now
does that help a little bit Julie well
it does you know I think maybe what I
need to do is is think about that face
and how he obtained it immediately and
we can do the same well that's exactly
right let me give you one more story you
know the story in the Bible of Zacchaeus
who climbed the tree so he could see
Jesus yes and he was let down through
the house no that's the key a fine tree
you're thinking about the other men that
went up on the roof Zacchaeus climbed a
tree
yes and this is an Luke chapter 19 so
that he could see Jesus and when Jesus
said the key has come down I'm going to
eat at your house today
it says the key has accepted him he
admitted that he had been stealing he
said I'm going to give back what I've
taken to the poor and give my riches the
poor pay back what I've stolen fourfold
as soon as he accepted Christ it says
Jesus says this is a son of Abraham he
was declared forgiven and righteous
Jesus said he would abide to this house
because the Kia's had accepted Christ
repented and confessed publicly and when
exactly forever or does that mean daily
or a moment-by-moment that's the other
clock well you get two phases you get
the part where you make the decision to
turn repent from your sins and follow
Jesus then you may slip along the way
and then you have sanctification where
you learn to live a new life okay thank
you thank you and you go ahead send for
that a new book I think you'll enjoy
that book that we're offering on 12
steps to revival it is free and you can
just go to the amazing facts website
thank you for your call Julie with that
we're going to talk next to Archie who's
been waiting patiently on Lodi
California Archie you're on the air yes
pastor Doug thank you for taking my call
many fathers have not and do not
actively treat their children as they
should this includes father's from every
strata of life how can we encourage
children and grown-ups who have been
hurt that our Father God is always
trustworthy and how can they become
acquainted with him well you know that's
a very perceptive observation it is true
first of all fathers should be loving
and patient with their children but
every father would say boy I wish I did
some things differently Colossians 3 21
s his father's provoked
your children to anger lest they be
discouraged other words encourage them
don't discourage I'm going to ride them
all the time you know fathers often my
father did you always want your kids to
be better than you are you want them to
excel and they kind of they just always
pushing them a little bit that's a
generalization but you know when I came
to the Lord I had to realize I need to
in my mind make a distinction I need to
separate my earthly father with all of
his problems for my heavenly father that
is perfect and God gives us a picture in
the Bible of what he is like as a
heavenly father and he is loving he is
good he's patient his compassion and
mercy endures forever and so you get a
new picture an example would be for
instance Archie if you look at the
example in the parable of the prodigal
son who he leaves home because maybe he
thinks his father is too hard but even
though he wastes his father's substance
and he wastes his life he comes back
home and his father embraces him with
open arms he finally realizes my father
always loved me and I didn't realize it
and it's a picture of our Heavenly
Father
sometimes people view God as a as a
cruel our harsh father that's exacting
and he's got his law and we need to obey
we only think about the rules and we
don't think about the relationship John
3:16 comes to mind
exactly God the father of course so
loved us he was willing to give his son
so that I think is the key and you know
all of us who are earthly fathers need
to do our best to model ourselves as
much as possible after our Heavenly
Father thank you very much hard to
appreciate your question and that does
open another line if you have a question
call in 800 4 6 3 7 2 9 7 that's 800 God
says or 800 4 6 3 7 2 9 7 with that
we're going to talk next to Denise who
is calling from Huntsville Alabama
Denise you're on the air with bottle and
slide taking my call after day
I was reading numbers 22 and verses 20
through 22 and it kind of just threw me
off the princes of Moab came to seduce
them into cursing the children of Israel
for the King Balak and God came to
Balaam and in the night and told them
that it was okay for him to go with the
princess to do this deed or what I would
let him go and then God after he gave
him approval then he got angry with him
and I kind of just kind of turned me off
that God got mad at Salem because Bailon
got up and decided to go with him the
next morning or whatever and God got mad
but he gave him approval so can you
explain to me how dad got mad after he
told him to go yeah I think the Lord
taught Balaam an object lesson on the
way first when the princess asked Balaam
to come and curse the children of Israel
God told Balaam tell him no says I bless
the children of Israel I don't want you
cursing them but Balaam wanted the
reward and he was sort of sorry that God
said no so the King Balak sent more
messengers with more money and they said
oh come on you've got to come here's an
even bigger reward and Balak was really
wanting to go and he said well let me
ask the Lord about it again well God
hadn't changed his mind but he kept
praying for what he wanted be careful if
you keep begging for something you may
get something that isn't God's will
he'll allow it but it's not as will and
even though God had said no he said all
right look I'll let you go
but if you go you're not going to be
able to curse him and you're not going
to get the reward and that should have
been an ode to Balaam but he said no I
want to go and he went anyway so along
the way of course the angel met the
donkey and God was illustrating to
Balaam says look the donkey is willing
to listen to me the donkey can see me
you can't and he had become so angry at
the donkey because it was going out of
the way and he wanted to go and get this
reward for Christian Israel so I think
God said okay I'm gonna let you go but
you know you're going the wrong way and
Balaam went and he tried to open his
mouth to curse God's people but every
time he prophesied
blessing came out and see God in this
story can control the voice of the
donkey the donkey was suddenly given the
ability to speak just like the devil
gave the serpent the ability to speak
and Balaam cannot say what he wants to
say he wants to curse Israel but when he
opens his mouth a blessing comes out in
the end you read later in the book of
Deuteronomy Balaam continues to try to
persuade Balak the king of Moab to
overthrow the children of Israel and he
says look if you just if you get the
people to commit adultery and break
God's commandments God will withdraw his
protection and there's finally a war
with Moab and Balak Balaam is slain so
you know he just was persistent he
started out as a prophet of God but like
Judas he became greedy well thank you
that answers it just let that help me
understand it and he gave me angle to
look at it that I didn't even think
about so thank you so much you're
welcome thank you
you know if for you and others that are
listening there's a book you can
probably download for free and it's
called prophets no patriarchs and
prophets patriarchs and prophets got a
chapter in there
it's a beautiful inspired commentary
chapter and there about Balaam that is
very insightful and that's where I
actually got some of my observations
thank you for your call Denise and with
that next we're going to talk to Cecilia
that's calling from Brooklyn New York
listening on 570 AM Cecilia you're on
the air
thank you for taking my call pastor yes
thank you for calling tonight
thank you I'm calling tonight to find
out if we had faith in Christ it says
that we're able to obey the law the law
we're able to obey it it it makes it
possible to obey God how can that be
just having the faith in Christ because
I still find myself at times falling
into sin even though I believe that
Christ is the atonement he has made the
atonement for my sin well let me give
you this say yes let me give you another
way to think of that
okay the word faith in the Bible means
belief or trust and give your parents
tell you in your child and your parents
say don't eat that cookie it might taste
good in your mouth but it's going to
give you a stomach ache well you're
thinking oh my parents are just trying
to scare me you don't totally believe
what they're saying so you eat the
cookie and it's good in your mouth at a
little while later you get a stomachache
anything well they were right well the
next day you see that cookie there and
they parents in the tone eat that cookie
I know it looks good which can give you
a stomachache ah you now believe them
and you obey Him because you believe
them you trust them you have faith in
their word you see what I'm saying so
it's very simple as we continue to grow
in our faith of God and God says please
do this and do not do that we are more
willing to do his will when we trust his
will is always going to be better for us
okay with that said then how do we take
our will out of Satan's will and give it
to Christ how do we do that in everyday
life then you know that that you are
asking the most important question do
you remember a story in the Bible
Cecelia where Jesus just before he went
to the cross he was in the Garden of
Gethsemane and he prayed three times
father not my will lie will be done yes
and he it was such a struggle he was
actually perspiring blood
I think the Gospel of Luke tells us he
was in great agony the other Gospels
tell us the biggest struggle any of us
faces from day to day is to trust our
will in the hands of God and saying I'm
going to give my will to you Lord I am
NOT going to do what I want but I am
going to resist the temptation whatever
it might be and do what I know you want
so denying self is a struggle but you do
have your own will now you mentioned the
will of the devil and you mentioned the
will of God but you left out one of the
very important ones you have a will and
God has made all of his creatures his
intelligent creatures with a free moral
choice and you do have the ability to
make a choice let me give you one
our illustration yeah let's suppose you
struggled with smoking and he said you
know I've tried to stop smoking I can't
stop smoking I've just got to have a
cigarette but then you found out that it
the next time you had a cigarette you're
going to get electrocuted if you really
knew if you really believed even if it
wasn't true if you really believed that
next 60 cigarette was going to illegally
electrocute you you could go a long time
without smoking because you would choose
so when a person directs their will they
surrender their will to God and they
make a choice there's a lot of power
that God has given every individual when
we really believe and so the question is
we've got to really believe that sin is
deadly that it hurts God it hurts us it
hurts others and so we surrender our
will to God and it's a struggle
sometimes the surrender of self is the
biggest struggle that anybody can face
hey I appreciate your question Cecilia
if you'd like I've got a free book I'll
be happy to send you and it's called the
surrender of self and if you'd like a
free copy of that just anybody if you'd
like to know more how to do that here's
a number to call it's called eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven now this is our resource line
summit will pick up they'll take your
information we'll send you a copy of the
book but if you ask for the book the
surrender of self they will send that to
you and I think you'll find it a
blessing thank you very much for your
question Cecilia and that does open a
line and here we got a lot of lines open
to that if you want to call in your
Bible question I'm gonna and that number
one more time to call in is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven that's 800 God says or four six
three seven two nine seven with that
we're talking next to Joe he's calling
from Florida
listening on satellite radio radio Joe
you're on the air hey how you doing
pastor Thank You indication we call
absolutely I had a I had a question
about
your take on one safe always saves
because you know if you look at Hebrews
eight where it talks about the new
covenant and he will forgive our sins
and our iniquities remember no more yes
you know that question is always up for
debate you know and I just wanted to get
your take on that because I can't think
of nothing on my own knowing that can
take us from out of the will of God well
first of all I just want to get your
take on ok I'll be happy to share with
you keep in mind that this is the big
one of the big debates among Christians
Protestants principally its free will or
predestination once saved always saved
or can we be saved and then be lost I am
of the opinion I would be in the
category of John Wesley and those who
believe that we can have assurance of
salvation but you can still choose to be
lost
after you've chosen to be saved like
this young lady I was just talking to a
minute ago we have a will so once a
person decides to follow the Lord God
will never let go of us but it doesn't
mean we've lost our freedom to turn from
him because you have examples in the
Bible of people like King Saul who was
filled with the Holy Spirit and chosen
by God and rejoiced in the Lord and led
the people but over the years he became
proud rebellious and he turned from God
and committed the unpardonable sin
ultimately he committed suicide you've
got you know others in the Bible like
Balaam I talked about Balaam was a
prophet of God but he persisted in greed
and he was lost and Peter talks about
those who were washed but they returned
to wallowing in the mire and Jesus says
in revelation to the Church of I think
it's maybe the Church of Sardis said
unless you repent I'll take your
candlestick out of its place and your
name can be removed from the book of
life and so that's pretty clear if a
person's name can be taken out of the
book of life then that means it's
dangerous to say once I'm saved I can do
anything I want and I can't be lost
that's the danger of that
people who believe that once I'm saved I
can be I can be lazy about
sanctification I can be sloppy about
living a holy life and no matter what I
do I'm going to be saved now see that's
the extreme I think that it is true once
we come to the Lord and we accept Jesus
we can trust that as we daily commit our
lives to him he will work in our lives -
sanctifies but it's an ongoing
relationship that's why Paul said I die
daily and this is why Jesus says in the
lord's prayer give us this day our daily
bread being a Christian is a day-by-day
trust in the Lord if there are not agree
100% and I'm a firm believer that you
have to do that daily yes that's the
most definite believer that you have to
do that daily yeah so so you can't get
lost easy exactly you know and now I've
written a book I'll send you a copy just
in case someone misunderstands people
people think that well if you don't
believe in once saved always saved you
must believe you're lost one day save
the next lost and then saved and then
Lawson and say I don't believe that
either so I wrote a book called
assurance justification made simple it's
a book called assurance and I'll be
happy to send you a free copy Joe if
you'd like you can call the resource
number which is 800 eight three five six
seven four seven and or you can read the
book at the amazing facts website which
is simply amazing facts dot o-r-g once
again anyone out there you'd like a copy
this you can read it online it's free
assurance justification made simple
we'll send you a copy all right thank
you very much Joe I'm going to talk real
quick to Sergio and Pennsylvania Sergio
you're on the air thank you for taking
my call yeah we've got just a couple
minutes for the break yes my question is
related to some passages in the New
Testament about predestination now is
pretty much what you said but I struggle
with the understanding that you seems
that God predestined some individuals to
be saved and you know maybe predestined
some
not to be saved despite their freewheel
right of actions so I just like you to
if you could clarify a little bit like
maybe I misunderstood but would be via
you know things are progressing some
individuals and maybe not others
yeah I think the Bible's pretty clear
that God doesn't want anyone to be lost
because the Bible tells us that the Lord
and this is 2nd Peter chapter 3 the Lord
is not willing that any should perish
and Paul says in Timothy God who would
have all men to be saved that doesn't
mean they all will be saved because
people have a will God doesn't want
anyone to be saved to be lon he wants
everyone to be saved they served you I
tell you what you've asked a great
question if you don't mind as holding on
and when I come back from after this
break I'll be happy to pick up that very
important question Brenda we're going to
be chased by the music for a brief break
for some of our affiliate carriers to
have a station identification and we do
still have lines open if you want to
call for the second half let's pick up
your phone it's 804 six three seven two
ninety seven we'll be right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
maybe facts has impacted and it's based
on four amazing facts amazing facts
actually did
process getting to where I am today I
feel good about that able to get it
there let's go I began reading the Bible
and I got baptized immersed and I
realized that there had to be more to
life is very good as the life that he's
coming this message it's like a lush
where we get amazing facts more than 45
years of reclaiming God's message around
the world and in the logo pops across
amazing facts presents I've listened to
a lot of different ministries but here
this was the first time that he's
actually saying something where I had to
grab my Bible actually pick it up and
I've never heard this before let me let
me look through him fine but I just
couldn't get enough and so I started
doing Bible space every single one of
these guys started being changed
including myself my question was why did
that happen to me God the Lord was able
to reach out and I actually saw him as a
father I lost everything and that's what
when I realized that it was gone missing
in my life I went to a prophecy seminar
which knocked me out this message was so
powerful and so irrefutable Moses went
this is real this is this is amazing
[Music]
every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call
or Bible answers live welcome back
listening friends and we know that some
have joined us in route this is the
Bible answers live program and if you
have a Bible question that's what we're
all about we do our best to study the
Word of God with our friends out there
and ask any question related to the
Bible and we don't have all the answers
but we will do our best in some great
Bible study resources at our fingertips
my name is Doug Batchelor Master John
Ross is off for the evening and we're
going to return to a question that came
in from Sergio Sergio was asking about
the will of God and predestination and
if God knows everything and if he's
chosen that you know if he's
all-powerful and some are saved and some
are not
is God somehow deciding who is saved or
who is not there's some verses that talk
about predestination in the Bible is
that sort of what you're asking Sergio
yes I understand your answer appreciate
it but uh my specific question is
according to some passages in the New
Testament there's God clearly say that
you know some some individuals were
predestined you know to be saved and if
that's true I found that I predestined
not to be saved no matter their free
will
yeah there's one verse where Paul says
in Romans Esau I hated and Jacob I loved
and people have taught thought that that
meant well that God just decided that
he's going to save and love Jacob and
he's going to destroy Esau but Paul is
actually quoting an Old Testament
prophet who is basically saying that the
people of Jacob I loved I made a
covenant with the children of Esau
because Esau rejected his birthright he
hated Jacob was spiritual he wanted the
birthright Esau was carnal he just
wanted some beans when he got hungry and
he was willing to sell his birthright
for beans is what it amounts to God is
not saying that he chose that Esau
should be lost and Jacob saved he said
that this is sin
of Esau who were carnal and earthly
minded he hated that and he loved the
descendants of Jacob that were looking
for spiritual things so some have
misunderstood that in a few other verses
by Paul but you know it's interesting
Peter in 2nd Peter chapter 3 Peter says
Paul the Apostle says some things that
are deep and if people are unstable and
unlearned they twist them to their
destruction many have taken some
statements of Paul and twisted them to
mean that God has decided ahead of time
who's going to be saved and who's going
to be lost now that wouldn't be very
fair because if God created some people
to be lost and then he puts him in the
lake of fire and punishes them for being
lost well he created them to be lost and
he punishes him for being lost where's
the justice in that you see what I'm
saying is real yes so the very fact that
God punishes the loss means that they're
responsible they've had a decision and
they've chosen poorly so hey I want to
send you a free book the book is can a
saved man choose to be lost
matter of fact friends this is a great
book any of you out there that have a
question about predestination or once
saved always saved I could not recommend
a book more strongly can a save man
choose to be lost you can get a free
copy by calling our resource line here
is the number 800 that's the toll-free
key eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven ask for the book can a
save man choose to be lost and you can
read that online for free at the amazing
facts web sort website I'm looking at it
right now at our website just click
underneath the media or the free library
and you'll see it there that's got all
the scriptures and it serves you and
you'll you'll really appreciate that
thank you for your call and with that
we're going to go now talk to Henry who
is calling from Grand Rapids Michigan
Henry first-time caller thank you for
calling
yesterday I had a question for you I
have no answer for
I've been in christian-like for 20 years
I can't figure it out
the question is when Jesus died on the
cross yep
there was a thief and he told this he
told us day you'll be with me in
paradise and ah the question is Jesus
didn't take the seat you're going to
take the thief to paradise because he
was he was in the tomb for three days
and he told Mary don't touch me for I
met I had a nightmare sinan yet right
and I'm wondering why he would tell
receive that and and when he was not he
didn't go to him himself yet you've
asked a very observant question that
many people have missed if you look at
that passage there in Luke chapter 23
Jesus is talking to the thief there on
the cross a thief turns to and says Lord
remember me when you come into your
kingdom and Jesus said verily I say to
you today you will be with me in
paradise now this is very important to
understand when the English translators
translate the Bible from the original
Greek it's originally written in Greek
Greek does not have punctuation
punctuation often tells us where to
pause and it helps us understand the
meaning a quick story years ago a lady
telegrammed her husband before they had
the telephones she sent a telegram from
Paris saying I found a beautiful Fox
coat I'd like to buy and he wrote her
back and said no price too high and so
she bought the coat well when she got
off the ship he said what are you doing
with a coat I said no price too high
well there was no comma and because
there was no comma they didn't
understand he was saying no price is too
high instead of saying no price is too
high see how that comma completely
changed the meaning what Jesus said to
the thief was verily I say to you today
then the comma you will be with me in
paradise the emphasis is not today
you'll be with me
paradise the emphasis is I'm telling you
today I'm making a promise to you today
though I don't look like a king and
though I don't look like a lord because
you called me Lord and King you will be
with me in paradise
so he never was emphasizing you'll be
with me in paradise this day he was
saying I am promising you today that you
will be with me in paradise so when they
did the punctuation there and some
translations have corrected that it in
the King James that I'll say verily I
say n tu cama today you'll be with me in
paradise we're really in the Greek it
says verily I say to you today , you
will be with me in paradise
see the difference I see the difference
one thing I can't figure out there's so
many scriptures in Revelations that it
talks about the sound of the trumpet and
the dead in Christ shall be risen first
and then Paul says to be absent from the
body is to be present with the Lord I
just get confused what to bleed okay
are you sound like you're wondering
heaven you're wondering when does a
person actually go to heaven with Jesus
and I've got a study guide that you can
either download for free or I'll send
you a copy and it's called are the dead
really did and it explains when the
resurrection happens it'll talk about
when the thief actually goes to be with
the Lord and it explains when the
trumpet sounds in first Thessalonians 4
and all the verses you just mentioned
are in that one study guide and
well-explained sounds like it's right up
the alley for what you're looking for
Henry if you just call 808 3 5 6 7 4 7
ask for the study guide are the dead
really dead 808 3 5 6 7 4 7 it explains
the resurrection when it's going to
happen we'll send you a free copy or
always you can read that study guide at
the amazing facts website which is
amazing facts comm by the way if you
probably if you youtube doug batchelor
are the dead really dead or even if you
did doug batchelor death I've got
several sermons I've done because
there's been so much confusion on that
subject we'll send you a free copy you
can watch it online and we thank you for
your call all right with that we're
going to go next and we're going
talk to Daphne who is listening from New
York and the Daphne are on the air with
Bible answers live thank you for waiting
your crowd yeah you're on yeah good
evening
he was just wondering what happened to
Ishmael mother didn't read anything
about her after that statement and she
was in the women is talking to God yeah
the Hagar was Ishmael's mother and
Abraham was told to divorce hey gar
because he had taken two wives he had a
son with Sarah finally Isaac and then he
had had a prior son with Hagar Ishmael
it was never God's plan that he should
marry Hagar and it was bringing strife
into the family and God said I want you
to give a settlement
he gave a gift to Hagar now instead of
going to Egypt and investing her money
she kind of got lost in the wilderness
for a while and the boy nearly died of
thirst but Ishmael grew into a great
tribe and a mighty people Hagar it does
say in the Bible Hagar took a wife for
Ishmael from Egypt she was from Egypt
and brought him to the desert where she
and and her people ended up growing so
Hagar probably lived a good long life
and died of old age she was kind of the
queen of the tribe of Ishmael but it
never kind of gives the day of her death
or any of those details in the Bible
you're right about that does that help a
little bit are you still with us Daphne
okay Daphne may be muted or off here
they thank you for thank you for your
your question and we appreciate that
we're going to talk next to Lawrence who
is calling from Newport Virginia
listening on 3abn Lawrence you're on the
air with Bible answers live yes plus hi
thank you for your call oh you're
welcome
oh this is my first time of calling well
we appreciate it and what is your
question for tonight
um I've come across a lot of stuff on
the internet like Bukovina and then I
was one
wondering if I have some clarification
about this book and then why it was not
our debt in the Bible yeah they're a
little book and it is they mitten like
Book of Enoch and what because I want to
be playing and then get my mind out of
it yeah
the Book of Enoch does exist the
question is was the Book of Enoch all
inspired Jude quotes from the Book of
Enoch in his book and at the book of
Enoch was a piece of literature that
wasn't written by Enoch of course you
know Enoch lived before the time of Noah
so the Book of Enoch to be authentic
would have had to somehow survive the
flood or be reproduced by Noah or Moses
or somebody there's no reference in
ancient Jewish literature to the Book of
Enoch the Book of Enoch only appears
after the Babylonian captivity so it's
believed that it was written and by
someone who was named Enoch or claimed
to be from Enoch it had some wonderful
inspirational statements in it Jude
quotes from one of those statements but
it doesn't mean the whole book is
inspired and so the book was not
included in the New Testament now most
of the New Testament books that you find
included in the Canon in the scripture
are either referenced to by the other
apostles or by Jesus himself the one
fleeting reference from Jude was not
enough for the the Bible those who
compiled the Bible or put the determine
which books they believed were inspired
to include it because it just sort of
appears out of nowhere in in history and
data because because Jude quotes from
the book doesn't mean the whole thing's
inspired Paul quotes from a Greek poet
meaning that Greek poet made an inspired
statement but it doesn't mean everything
the poet ever wrote was inspired see
what I'm saying yes I think Abraham
Lincoln's speech of the Gettysburg
Address was inspired but doesn't mean
everything Lincoln said was inspired so
Jude chose to quote from a small segment
in the Book of Enoch
did talk about the second coming that he
believed was in harmony with the Bible
but the whole book was not okay all
right
does that help a little bit yes and
there hey thank you so much appreciated
Lawrence and yeah check us out at
amazing facts dot o-r-g you'll find a
lot more material there all right going
next talk to Freddy Freddy in Brooklyn
New York listening on wmca welcome
Freddy you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi how are you I'm much
better than I deserve my question is in
the chapter 3 of the book of Daniel it
talks about the three Hebrew boys being
thrown into the fiery furnace yes and it
goes further to say when the King
Nebuchadnezzar looked into the fire he
saw four my question is when after after
he called all the trees Hebrew boys out
of the fiery furnace what happened
before the fourth person saw in the
fiery furnace was he burned up no King
Nebuchadnezzar when he said did we not
throw sir by the way this is Daniel 3
verse 24 after he threw Shadrach Meshach
and Abednego in the fire it says the
king was astonished and he rose up and
he spoke and said didn't we throw three
men in the fire bound how come I see
four and then he goes on and says the
form of the fourth is like the Son of
God so God sent an angel to be with them
in that furnace to protect them just
like if you read in Daniel chapter 6
when Daniel was thrown in the lion's den
Daniel said my God has sent his angel
and shut the lion's mouth God sent an
angel to protect Daniel and so that when
they came out of the den the angel just
you know he disappeared became invisible
again but either the angel or God's son
himself came to preserve them and
encourage them when they were thrown in
the furnace for their faith he still
there Freddie that's all right some of
the word that makes sense make then
alright hey I appreciate your call
that's a good question and even I got
some new ideas while I was just looking
at that with you sometimes as I study
with others
I get edified myself alright we're going
to talk next to Robert and we do have
another couple of lines free before I go
to Robert just reminding you go to
calling your questions eight hundred
four six three seven two ninety seven
with your Bible questions still have
time for a few more calls are going to
talk Robert in college place Washington
on KFI a Robert you're on the air well
pastor done hi you're going to kno
tonite
regarding the Torah I know there's
Sabbath laws in the Old Testament and
about wearing a wearing something on
your clothes a tick-tock tick it says
whatever is called the flattering things
you that you raped or something all
those catalogs where as what is the
Torah fit in with all these laws and
yeah I know there's ceremonial laws that
we're done away with but what about the
Sabbath laws wearing things on your
clothes or tassels and all those other
kind of things well you've got you know
the the word Torah it means the
instruction it is sort of a broad term
that can refer to the law typically it
refers to the first five books of Moses
the priests they were to wear sometimes
garments or borders of blue to remind
them about the law of God and so if
you're asking specifically about that
part of the Torah well you know we don't
have the Jewish priesthood anymore when
Christ died two things were torn when
Jesus died on the cross it says that the
veil and the temple was torn and the
meaning that we don't use the temple
anymore to sacrifice Christ as our lamb
and the high priest tore his garments
meaning that we're not under the old
priesthood anymore but Christ is our
high priest and we are a nation of
priests so we don't need to all go
around wearing the Jewish robes anymore
we're not under that those articles so
was there anything other specific
question about the Torah
and now I just know that there's people
that are Torah observant and I know that
serious ammonia lawns have begun away
with so I just well yeah keep in mind
when you think of the Torah some people
are referring to the five books of Moses
and it is the written Torah that's all
in the Bible but they've got the spoken
Torah which were the commentaries of the
rabbi's over time on the books of Moses
they are not inspired because there was
almost no end of rabbis and people who
had comments some of them are very zany
some were very good and so I want to put
a lot of stock in the spoken Torah
and that maybe some of what you're
reading the sayings of the different
live rabbits about if you want to know
what the true Torah is read the five
books of Moses Genesis Exodus numbers
Deuteronomy and Leviticus and I actually
didn't just give them an order but those
are the five books and that's inspired
part of the Word of God then you've got
all the rabbi commentaries on that
that's some of the extended Torah the I
want to put a lot of stock in that so I
don't know if that helpings at all helps
it all Robert with your question yes
thank you all right hey thank you very
much appreciate your call
let me see we do still have a couple
lines open if you have a question eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven brings you to the Bible answers
live studio all right it's going to talk
next to Alden who is listening from Las
Vegas and you got a question Alden yes
that's very bachelor it's finally nice
to be able to talk to you my wife and I
listen to you all the time especially
during Shabbat well bless your heart
yeah we appreciate your calling in all
right we're calling it from Las Vegas I
have a question regarding the message of
the Bible stating that you shall not
judge and I get hit with this all the
time people saying that you can't judge
me you can't judge it you know anything
that I believe in but yet I understand
that yet Jesus said before
you judge you should remove the plank
out of your eye and so on and so forth
so the question is the Bible says that
we should have discernment and for me
it's kind of like a fine line between
discernment and judging can you comment
on that yeah it's probably one of the
most misquoted or misapplied verses in
the Bible is the one that says judge not
or don't judge the Bible doesn't really
say we should never use judgment matter
of fact Paul condemns the Corinthian
church because they did not judge a
brother who was sleeping with his
stepmother and he said look like you
know you you should be able to judge in
these kind of matters that this fellow
should be put out of the church he's
doing something that's being mocked by
the Gentiles jesus said when you judge
use a righteous judgment and say if you
judge so we're given you no brains and
God wants us to reason with him and
there's times we exercise judgment he
doesn't want us condemning others
because you know when we condemn another
person we could bring condemnation on
ourselves if we're going to try to
encourage a brother or sister in the way
of righteousness then Paul said you know
make sure that you're not doing the very
fighters that you're talking I don't be
an issue with not being hypocritical
when making a judgment call yeah exactly
Jesus said if you're going to help a
person with the speck in their eye make
sure you don't have two by four in your
own eye so otherwise you know Tupac
recei and you're being inconsistent but
yeah at the same time we don't want to
go around condemning people but the Lord
does yeah we don't want to have the
attitude that Cain had when God said
where is your brother and Cain said well
you know I don't want to judge my
brother I'm not their brother's keeper
who cares about my brother so you've got
that extreme where Christians just don't
care about anyone because they say I
don't want to be accused of judging so
we don't care about anyone's condition
and then you've got the other extreme
where we kind of go around and we're
more righteous than everyone else and
looking down on others and condemning
them that's the other extreme
so yeah don't judge is often misapplied
in the Bible does that very much oh yes
it does it clarifies it greatly thank
you very much for your time thank you
Alden you know we do have a book we'll
send you a free copy and it's called
facing the judge and it talks about
judgment and all you've got to do is
call 808 three five six seven four seven
one more time 808 three five six seven
four seven asked for the book facing the
judge and we do a preacher appreciate
your call okay with that we're going to
talk next to Chris who's calling from
Canton that's on W mu Z Chris you're on
the air
hi hi I would like to know we have some
longtime friends that have uh you know
believe in the Lord and they've been
faithful Christians in the way they live
but they don't believe in doctors or
different things to keep you healthy and
alive and they have a daughter right now
that's very sick and she hadn't gone to
the doctor to get the procedure and
things she was supposed to and now
doesn't look good at all I don't know
how to approach this because we've known
for years they've been generous they've
been kind but I think I prejudged them
because I thought you know he was being
foolish that thinking you couldn't get
doctors had serve a purpose yeah you
know the Bible does say that we can turn
to the Lord and trust him for healing
one of the ways God sometimes sends
healing is by giving us people that can
give treatment and so it's not a lack of
faith if a doctor says you know here
I've got a solution for your sickness
it's this procedure it's this medicine
so how could I approach it if I I know
I'll be around them at some point here
in the near future well you can show
them there's a story in the Bible where
King Hezekiah you can remember that King
Hezekiah was weighted down King King
Hezekiah was sick
and he prayed and Elijah the prophet
told him he needed to put a plaster on
his boil and he was healed so God used a
procedure for him to be healed God could
have miraculously spoken away night I
should tell you this he rubbed honey all
over his wife no she's not well either
oh well I don't know that I'd recommend
that but that's not it that yeah that's
change anyway but you know you can show
them that and help them see that there
are examples in the Bible where God uses
doctors one of the New Testament books
the book of Luke is written by a
physician and so Luke did not give up
being a physician when he accepted Jesus
he did not give up caring about the poor
and the sick and the gifts are healing
or one of the gifts that God gives
people and that doesn't mean all
miraculous healing where you just wave
your hand and speak over them anyway so
hopefully that will help a little bit
and you can point them to that story
there in the Book of Isaiah about King
Hezekiah when he was sick and he prayed
and God used a medical procedure to help
him listening friends we are just about
out of time but before we go off the air
I want to remind you that amazing facts
you can access so much information
through the ministry's website which is
simply amazing facts dot o-r-g we have a
Facebook page I've got a personal
Facebook page I'd love to be your friend
you can just go to Doug Batchelor and
you can be friends there I do
communicate with the people on my
Facebook page and look at all those
videos and the studies that we have
online we've got about 50 years worth of
material for you to study to enrich you
in your relationship with the Lord and
just to strengthen you also help keep us
on the air you can donate online amazing
facts Arg
god bless you we are looking forward to
a chance to study his word together
again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G are you wondering what
lies ahead in human history or what
piece of world events are harbingers of
the end are you ready for the coming
crisis landmarks of prophecy offers
clear answers to your most pressing
questions presented by pastor Doug
Batchelor landmarks of prophecy is a
contemporary video Bible study adventure
designed for today's audiences
presenting the landmark themes of the
Bible in a bright and compelling way
helping you understand the Bible better
and giving you knowledge to face the
future with confidence landmarks of
prophecy contains over 30 hours of
exciting video presentations on six DVDs
plus bonus question and answer sessions
giving you keen insight into what lies
next in human history if you'd like
practical tools to help you thrive and
survive in the here and now get
landmarks of prophecy start your epic
Bible study adventure with landmarks of
prophecy today by calling
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF Axio RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
[Music]